. . . . . . . . . . . Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich geb's so, verstanden. Hey, doch. Können wir gerne... Das ist die Tür. Vor ein paar Folgen habe ich der Welt da draußen gesagt, dass meine Badezimmertür lustige Geräusche macht, nämlich achs. Ein Twitter-User, nämlich Paul, hat uns geschrieben, können Sie mir das mal geben? Ich habe gesagt, ein Kumpel von mir komponierte auch gerade schon eine ganze Symphorie drauf. Genau, nämlich ein anderer Kumpel hat nämlich, also die Idee ist ja, Beethoven hat sich ja auch inspirieren lassen von bababam. Ja, vom Klopfen seiner Nachbarn oder was war das, hat man da recherchiert? Nee, sein Vater hat am Tisch abends gesessen und hat. Moment mal, was war das, Papa? Ich habe gehustet. Ich habe Ich habe gehustet, wir haben ja alle alle Cholera-Pest. Ich weiß, es tut mir auch leid, dass das Geld alles für mein riesiges Cembalo draufgeht und weniger für die Krankenversicherung, die wir so dringend brauchen. Aber trotzdem, Vater, mach das nochmal, bitte. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da zur Verfügung stellen, meine Tür macht Ja, es ist ein melakonisches Zehren, das Hinreichen zerrt mich auf. Auch dieses Zerrissen sein, will ich auf sein, will ich zu sein, wo gehöre ich hin? Aber ist das Geräusch beim Öffnen oder beim Schliessen der Tür? Oh, beim Öffnen. Oh, beim Öffnen der Tür, also du öffnest sozusagen die Leidenschaft und verzerrst dich quasi auf zu lange Zeit. Nee, ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht sicher gerade. Auf jeden Fall ist es ein bisschen wie diese Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy Türen, die mal stöhnen. Ich finde auch immer eine gute Idee. Wollen Türen offen sein oder zu? Eben. Das ist die Frage. Fenster ist klar. Fenster wollen zu sein. Fenster wollen zu sein. Die sagen, hier ist Schluss, ich bin auch Teil der Wand, bin wichtig. Manchmal sind sie auf, es ist Durchzug und sie gehen zu. Also deutlicher können uns Gegenstände ja nicht sagen, was sie wollen. Das stimmt. Meinst du, Fenster denken sich manchmal, wenn sie aufgemacht werden, so, wow, wow, wow, ich bin Teil der Wand, nicht, dass ihr was einstürzt. Und dann ist es nur Kipp. Nicht, dass ihr was einstürzt. Erstens das. Und dann ist es nur Kipp. Also, okay, okay, okay, we got this, langsam. Ich falle, ich falle, oh, oh, okay. Jeffrey, Jeffrey, du bist auf Kipp, alles gut, okay? Hämmer mich auf, hörmer mich auf, hörmer mich auf. Okay, aber dass sie denken, sie sind Teil der Wahl. Ja, die überschätzen sich masslos, Fenster sind Riesenwichser. Ich meine, ich glaube, die Fenster sind wie so, wenn man irgendwie so ein Auto schiebt oder so zu fünft. Ja. Und einer macht nicht mit, so, der macht die Bewegung, aber er drückt nicht. Und ich glaube, so ist das Fenster sind wie so, wenn man irgendwie so ein Auto schiebt oder so, zu fünft und einer macht nicht mit, so,
der macht die Bewegung, aber er drückt nicht.
Und ich glaube, so ist das Fenster auch, das macht
immer, das versucht immer hochzuhalten, die Wand,
aber es hat kaum Kraft, weil es aus Glas.
Es ist aus fucking Glas, jetzt erklär
nochmal, wie Glas gemacht wird.
Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt,
Brand, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt,
Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt. Das ist Stefan Tietze übrigens, den ihr hier an der Orgel hört, noch hat er den ersten Ton nicht angestimmt, aber er sitzt an einer Orgel. Und dein Name ist mir entfallen. Genau, wir sitzen hier in der St. Christophoruskirche in Münster. Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt. Du bräuchtest eigentlich so, ich meine, früher gab es ja Medien, jetzt sage ich mal nicht in dem Sinne wie heute, sondern es gab nur die Sinfonie. Und wenn du was hören wolltest, musstest du die Sinfonie hören. Aber jetzt gab es ja wenig... Die News wurden mit Sinfonie? Ja, oder halt Bildungsauftrag. Das, was heute so was ist, was ist... In Musik. Ja musst du dann halt irgendwie unterbringen mit verschiedenen Funfacts oder so.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich recherchiere gerade intensiv zum Thema Boa Constrictor, die Würgeschlange und die wirkt ja alles weg, also die Ferg ist es, die wirkt dich weg. Glaubst du, die Top drei würgenden Tiere, würrige Tiere, da ist die Boa Constrictor ganz oben mit dabei.
Ich glaube, die ist relativ dabei. Jetzt nagelt mich nicht darauf fest, aber Constrictor kommt doch auch von Constrare zusammenziehen. Wegwürgen, genau, Constraro, Constraras, Constrarat und dann natürlich der Würgeaffe auf zwei auf zwei. Klar. Und der Schmetterling. Überraschend auf drei. Aber nicht zu trotz, gönnen wir ihm den dritten Platz. Aber ich finde es so geil, weil wenn ich mir überlegen würde, also ich hätte Tiere und ich hätte verschiedene Skills und ich müsste die so verteilen, ich würde natürlich der Schlange Würgen geben, weil die ist ein Seil. Ja. Die Schlange ist ein Seil. Ja. Und es ist einfach, dass die wirkt, ist einfach eine gute Idee. Vielleicht hat auch jemand gesehen, wie eine Schlange wirkt und dann gesagt hat, wir haben doch Seide. Das können wir doch auch machen. Hat man so ein Quietsche-Entchen in der Schlange hingelegt und dann wirkt die das und macht es piep. Oh, sorry. Schlangen erschrecken sich gar nicht, glaube ich. Die sind extrem souverän. Aber dann dachte ich mir, jetzt mal rein biologisch gesprochen, du kannst ja nur Dinge erwürgen, die eine Lunge haben. Die das zulassen. Einerseits das. Die dumm genug sind, das zuzulassen. Aber du brauchst ja eine Lunge, weil die Idee des Würgens ist ja, dass du sich so zusammendrückst. Genickbruch. Weiß ich nicht.
Erst mal ganz kurz, viel Tiere haben Lügen. Lass mich erst mal die fünf Funfacts droppen,
die ich gelernt habe über die Bohrkonstriktor.
Die Bohrkonstriktor, die Schlange,
die umarmt dich erst mal und immer wenn du
ausatmest, dann geht
deine Brust nach innen,
dann zieht sie enger.
Das heißt, ich glaube, die hat gar nicht so viel Kraft,
sondern die muss ja auf den richtigen Moment warten, um immer enger zu ziehen, wo sich Raum gibt. Das wusste ich nicht. Und dann bist du irgendwann raus, weil du kannst irgendwann nicht mehr einatmen, weil dazu müsste ja deine Brust sich vergrößern. Aber immer wenn du ihn locker lässt, schnallt sie die Wirkung enger. So, und jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, klar, das passt für mich für alle Tiere, die eine Lunge haben. Aber nicht alle Tiere haben eine Lunge. Muss ich aber sagen, die haben sich jetzt eine gute Zielgruppe ausgesucht, weil Lungen sind relativ verbreitet. Relativ verbreitet. Ich musste eine Weile recherchieren, um ein Tier zu finden, das keine Lunge hat, stellt sich raus die Wirbellosen. Keine Wirbel, keine Lunge. Warum heißen die nicht Lungenlose? Das sind die Regeln der Welt. Kein Wirbel, keine Lunge. Keine Wirbel, keine Lunge, kein Service. Ganz einfach. Kein Geld. Kein Geld, keine Lunge. Ich bin ein scheiß Wirbeltier. Ich bin eh schon gebeutelt, eine gebeutelte Minderheit. Beuteltier. Ein gebeuteltes Beuteltier sagt so, Leute, ich stehe direkt neben euch. Halt mal dein dummes Maul, du gebeuteltes Beuteltier. Ich habe kein Geld, keine Lunge, kann nicht würgen. Ja, aber Moment, Moment, Moment. Kein Wirbel, keine Lunge, kein Problem, das Motto der Wirbellosen, denn nicht jeder hat Wirbel. Wir Menschen stolzieren ja aufrecht mit unserem Riesenwirbel rum und wir wirbeln uns durch die Gegend. Aber auch mit Lungenentzündungen, denn wer keine Lunge hat, kriegt er keine Lungenentzündung. Wirbelentzündung. Und dann kommen wir nämlich zu den Wirbellosen, zur Krabbe. So, und dann dachte ich mir, woher weiss die Schlange, also gab es in der Geschichte der Natur, der langen, langen, zu langen, vielleicht? Ja, ich finde auch zu langen. Die Geschichte der Natur die Situation, dass eine Schlange, eine Wirbelschlange versucht hat, ein Tier zu wirken, das keine Lunge hat und das einfach nicht ersticken kann. Zum Beispiel diese Kokoskrabben, die größten wirbellosen Tiere der Welt. So, aber wo haben die denn, wie atmen die denn Sauerstoff ein? Die haben Trosophyllen und die, die haben so Löcher im Körper und da kommt Luft direkt rein. Stängende und Lunge. Was ist deine Definition von Lunge? Eine Lunge ist ja eine Pumpe. Und es gibt ja die, die pumpen und die, die einfach saugen. Das ist ja einfach nur so eine Art Filter. Ich finde, eine Lunge ist doch erstmal für mich, die Definition für Lunge, ein Sauerstoffbeherbergend, ein Sauerstoffakku. Das Tolle an Wissenschaft ist ja, dass du dich nicht selber darum kümmern musst, Dinge zu definieren. Und das gefällt mir nicht. Die sind ja schon definiert. Das gefällt mir nicht. Du musst ja nicht sagen, jetzt lass mich mal gucken, was Organ das mit Sauerstoff zu tun hat. Nett, aber das ist nicht die Definition. Und deswegen glaube ich... Ich bin Wissenschaftsskeptiker. Okay. Nee, ich glaube, du hättest nur gerne deine eigene Wissenschaft. Vielleicht wärst du gerne Wissenschaftler geworden, aber dann kam diese Medienwelt und hat dich, wie auf so einem Jahrmarkt mit so einem Greifarm, hat dich so rausgezogen und du wolltest noch gar nicht raus aus der Studienwelt. Ich hing so dran wie so ein Hund, den man so hochhebt. Da hing ich dann so dran und wurde dann einfach fallen gelassen. Nee, ich möchte gerne meine eigenen Fakten erfinden. Das ist anstrengend, weil es wurde schon sehr viel geschrieben. Auch hier würde ich sagen, zu viel. Und dann ist halt die Frage, muss man das alles lesen? Und so kann man ja nicht, kann ich ja nicht. Das ist ja nicht menschenmöglich. Ist aber ein guter Punkt. Wenn du eine Katze hochhebst, die wehrt sich, die kratzt dich, der Hund, oh. Oh, was passiert jetzt? Keine Reaktionsmöglichkeit, nicht vorgesehen. Nee. Nicht vorgesehen. Ich bleib jetzt mal in dieser Position, bis ich abgesetzt werde, wieder. Ach, da berühren meine Füsse wieder Boden. Und dann wird weiter Hundefragen im Kopf. Da hatte ich kurz einen Blackout. Da hat er mich gepackt und dann war ich kurz weg. Und dann... Aber jetzt ist dieser Boa Constrictor, geht auf die Krabbe los. Genau. Die grösste Kokoskrabbe der Krabbenwelt. Genau. Denkt sich, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, ich mach meinen Würgetrick. Würgt die? Umarmt die erst freundlich. Genau, zur Begrüssung. Die sagt Check. Lass dich mal drücken, komm mal hin. Und dann würgt die, kriegt's nicht hin, weil Krabbe hat jetzt plötzlich keine Lunge. Genau, Krabbe hat keine Lunge, kann nicht ersticken und das ist natürlich unangenehm. Weil die Krabbe kommt nicht mehr raus und sagt, Alter, weißt du, ich verstehe, was du machen willst, aber das funktioniert rein biologisch. Hey, Kollege, ja, sorry, ganz kurz, ich weiß, du bist gerade sauer anstrengend, nur ganz kurz, ich bin eine Krabbe, ich habe keine Lunge, kannst du kurz, das wird nichts. Wie kannst du dann reden? Ohne Lunge, ich check nichts. Klapper, Klapper, Klorophyll. Aber du musst doch Sauerstoff bekommen. Ja, aber durch kleine Löcher in meinem Panzer ... Aber wenn ich die alle zuhalte, ich kann die alle zudrücken. Das kannst du nicht, das tut mir leid. Wie lange machen wir das jetzt noch? Panzer zum Platzen bringen. Ich kann einen Panzer-Patzer-Patze. Na, probier's. Kannst du den Smash-It ... Sand weggebrannt, Sand weggebrannt. Aber entweder man kann der alle Knöpfe zudrücken oder den Panzer zum Platzen. Aber du meinst, wenn man alle Knöpfe gleichzeitig drückt, dann geht es kaputt. Egal bei was. Es ist nicht dieser Urban Legend, sehr wenig Urban, aber am Set von Golden Eye oder Goldfinger, einer von diesen Bond-Filmen, da ist ja einer ganz gold angemalt worden, und dann wurde aber, ist ja, oder die Schauspielerin gestorben, weil zu viel bemalt wurde, weil wir ja auch über die Haut atmen. Weird, da Geschichte. Ich glaube nicht, dass die gestorben ist, aber ich glaube, es ist, man läuft Gefahr, weil auch der Mensch anscheinend über die Haut atmet. Aber dann in unsere Lunge rein, oder ist das das, was die Krabben machen? Jesus Christ, ist einfach weird.
Das mag ich nicht an Wissenschaft, dass man immer so ein, zwei Fragen beantworten kann, aber dann einfach nicht weiter. Das geht ja nicht weiter.
Warum bist du so tief drin in dem Boa Constrictor Tunnel?
Ich habe mir überlegt, weil ich überlege mir, wenn man geboren wird, ist dann der Magen voll, hat man noch so einen Vorrat Oder hat man richtig fucking Hunger? Also wie schnell nach der Geburt muss man essen? Oder hat man erst mal so ein, du bist erst mal gut. Also wie wenn du dir ein Gerät kaufst, ist die Batterie aufgeladen. Plug and play. Plug and play, so. Und du kannst erst mal machen, was du willst. Menschen sind so fucking plug and play. So, und jetzt die Frage, weil das Kind im Mutterleib kriegt ja To-Go über die Nabelschnur, Genau. Halt Schlüfter, Fr plug and play. So, und jetzt die Frage, also, weil das Kind im Mutterleib hat ja, kriegt ja to go über die Nabelschnur, halt schlürft da Fruchttiger oder was auch immer, und dann kommt es raus und dann ist es aber erstmal gut. Nee, erstmal dann kommt die Nabelschnur durchgekappt. Das ist ja der Moment, wo zum ersten Mal... Und dann nimmt der Arzt aber selber nochmal so einen Schlürf, so... Da ist ja in der, da ist ja in der Kabel, ist ja noch drin. Ich wollte nur kurz sagen, dass da alles gut lief eigentlich. Kann ich auch mal einen haben. Nee, es ist mein Mittagessen. Und dann macht er sich, oh Gott, ist das widerlich. Oh Gott, ist das ekelig. Ja, natürlich keine Komplikationen, zwölf vor acht. So ein Bröckchen. Mittagessen können Sie absagen. Ja, oh Gott, das ist das ekligste, was ich jemals vorgestellt habe. Aber was ist da drin? Ich weiss es auch nicht genau. So etwas wie Astronautennahrung, so Hugh, Hugh, Hugh, Hugh. So Gogurt, so flüssige N, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so du hast erstmal ein gewisses, alle, also genau wie wenn du in einem Videospiel einen neuen Charakter erstellst, sind alle Lebensbalken erstmal voll. Du startest ja nicht mit halber Lebensinnerung, das ist ja Quatsch. Ja, oder so Tutorial-mäßig so, da geht nichts schief. Wenn man schief geht, we got your back, dann gehst du erstmal raus auf die Welt, ich glaube, du hast erstmal keinen Hunger, nee. Und dann dachte ich mir, die Bohr-Konstriktor, was ist, wenn die auf die Welt kommt und die ist winzig klein, wie so ein kleiner Regenwurm? Wie ist die? Muss die direkt wirken? Kommt die raus? Weil normalerweise dachte ich mir... Verhebt dich nicht, verwirkt dich nicht. Verwirkt dich nicht. Jetzt nicht, du musst dann erstmal die Kleinen... Nein, du versuchst dich gerade an einem Elefanten. Das ist auch für mich, dein Papa. Ist das ein bisschen zu viel? Ja. Du bist noch ganz klein, du könntest klein dein Baby schlagen. Wie so ein Armreif von so einem Reh, so eine kleine Boa-Konstrikte und die so, was ist das denn? Und die so, aber was ist einfach nichts. Und Bambi ist so mega stolz auf ihr geiles Accessoire. Der Joker holt sich einen Joker. Hi, hi, hi, hi Frederik. Aber da weiss ich, weil normalerweise denke ich mir, die Elterntiere holen Essen für die Kleinen, aber Schlangen verschlingen ja immer ihr Essen vollständig, Schlangen können die nicht abbeissen. Und dann dachte ich, die Mutter... Haben Schlangenlungen? Die Mutter... Komm weg von diesem Lungen-Thema. Die Mutterboa, die kann ja nicht was abbeissen von dem Reh und das dem Kleinen geben, sondern die verschlingen die ja immer vollständig. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie teilen die, wie können die, also Tiere, die kein Essen teilen können, wie versorgen die ihren Nachwuchs? Oder wirkt das dann wirklich so eine Fledermaus oder so was Kleines? Ja, was Kleines, Fliege. Aber die muss das immer erwischen als kleine, dusselige, langsame Schlange. Ja, genau. Was ich wissen will, ist, wie viel fucking Stress hat so eine Boa-, die sagt, ich habe jetzt zwei Tage Zeit, sonst bin ich tot. Also mein Magen ist aktuell voll. Du meinst, das ist wie so ein Countdown. Ich glaube, ja. So ein intrinsischer Stress. Ja, genau. Ich habe noch zwei Tage Zeit, sonst bin ich tot. Und der erste Tag, du chillst erst mal, der erste Tag guckst du dich erst mal um, oh, Farben, toll, Wasser, oh, das ist heiß, oh, 3D-Bilder, kriege ich die schon hin, richtig zu gucken oder noch nicht, mach ich morgen. Und dann, nächster Tag ist Stress. Was macht eine Schlange, wenn es juckt? Hinten rechtslöst. Die dreht sich ganz schnell einfach. Die wirbeln. Die haben so Probleme, und wie kommen die oben ans Regal, alles ist weird, Schlangenleben sind einfach alles Problem, man kriecht am Ende des Tages nur von Problem zu Problem. Das ist, was ich denke. Nee, da hören wir mal zu. Nee, absolut. Nee, ich will nicht, ich kriege hier von Problem zu Problem. In einem langsamen Tempo kommt dazu. Und neulich habe ich versucht, mehr Essen zu erwürgen. Turns out, keine Lunge. Frederik die Krabbe hat keine Lunge. Völlig umsonst. Locker 45 Minuten habe ich gedrückt und gedrückt, nichts passiert. 45 Minuten Sesh. Der hat mich ausgelacht. 45 Sesh gehabt. 45 Minuten Sesh. Der hat mich ausgelacht. Hat ich auch ausgelacht. Mit seiner Krabbenlache. Und dann, wenn du was fängst, das zu gross ist, kannst du auch nicht essen. Vor allem, die Krabbe ist auch das einzige Thema, was sich gut verteidigen könnte gegen die Würgerattacke. Ja. Einfach nur schneidet einfach durch. Oh Gott. Schneidet in der Mitte durch. Ich glaube, Krabbe ist nicht. Vielleicht ist Krabbe so der Hard-Counter zur Schlange, dass die sich ja so entwickelt haben, so als Hard-Counter, dass die genau die gegen das andere Tier gut sind. Das ist schon schwierig. Warum heißt das Sternzeichen Krebs im Englischen auch Cancer? Ist es so? Ich glaube, aber ich glaube, das Tier heißt auch Cancer. Es gibt, glaube ich, irgendeine Verbindung zwischen der Krankheit und dem Tier. Vielleicht hat man früher gedacht, dass die die Krankheit auslösen. So wie man früher alles auf Ratten geschoben hat und so. Dass das Pizza-Hut-Phänomen, weil es im Deutschen Pizza Hut ist und das Logo sowohl als Hütte als auch als Hut durchgeht. Ja, das stimmt. Alles ist merkwürdig. Ja, es ist wirklich merkwürdig. Der Pizza-Hut, ja. Und das neue Logo, haben die das Logo geändert und ich war wieder ein Tag, ich konnte eine Nacht nicht schlafen wieder, schon wieder wegen Pizza hat. Weil die haben das Logo geändert und es geht wieder als fucking Hut und Hütte durch. Und jetzt ist es fast noch mehr zu einem Hut geworden. Aber meinst du, da gibt es irgendeinen Repräsentanten, einen deutschen Repräsentanten im grossen Klinikum von Pizzat, der sagt, Guys, I have to say that there is one additional problem we got. Your mic is off. Oh, I'm sorry. Guys, I like the new logo. Carl, we're done here. I know, I know, I know, but I got to intervene now.
There is one big problem.
With the new logo, I like it, it is very trendy, but look. We just voted.
Look at, Guy, I know.
Guy, listen to me, Guy.
Because I know that there is one big thing in Germany, you know, it's hat.
It's pizza hat.
No, it's pizza hat.
No, it's hat.
Everywhere it's pizza hat.
In German, trust me, I was a German for too much of my life, I admit.
But it looks like a hat and it sounds like a hat.
And the new logo has also to be a hat.
You know, this is extremely important.
I know this is a tiny detail for you.
Can we get Gary in?
No, I know this is...
Guys, please, this is a tiny detail for you.
Okay, you're right.
But this is very important for us Germans.
We love the pizza. We love the cheap pizza. It's great, we love it. Let me just ask Gary, Gary, can we get it a bit more head-like? Just a tiny bit more head-like for fucking Carlis. Yeah, okay. Okay, thank you. Thank you guys so much. Germany will forever be grateful to you. if you have anything that you need on your pizza for everything you have a big big favor with us. Thank you so much. Good luck and let's power on. Your mic was off again. Yeah, thank you guys. Aber alle lassen ihn ausreden. Alle lassen ihn ausreden, aber haben keinen Bock darauf. Wah Wahnsinn, ich weiß gar nicht, was das neue Pizza Hut-Logo ist. Ja, das Pizza Hut. Logos, alle ändern gerade ihre Logos. Das teuerste Logo der Welt war übrigens lange das Pepsi-Logo. Und jetzt ist es wieder neu gemacht worden. Es kommt gerade wieder ... Das heißt, das alte Pepsi-Logo ist jetzt frei. Das heißt, wir könnten jetzt theoretisch ... Das ist aber sehr ähnlich. Aber wenn die es nicht mehr benutzen, ich meine, wer es nicht benutzt, weggeschmissen wird hier gar nichts. Das ist eh klar. Wir sind die Recyclingtonne der Popkultur sind wir hier. Also ich bin nicht das, was weggeschmissen wird. Wir haben unseren Logomüll um 80 Prozent reduziert dieses Jahr. Ich muss nur sagen, man hat jetzt gerade beobachtet einen Trend, den ich wieder ganz gut finde. Früher waren Logos super verschnörkelt, viel drin, viel Details. Dann gab es so eine Minimalismuswelle, alles nur noch so 2D-mäßig und jetzt kommt es zurück, so eine Tiefe. Das finde ich spannend, ich mag das sehr gerne. Und jetzt wird alles wieder so ein bisschen 80s-mäßig. Und du meinst nicht, dass einfach nur Logodesigner sagen, oh shit, jetzt ich ab... Wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten, wir haben die eine jetzt gemacht. Wir können jetzt nur noch, entweder wir machen das nochmal, also so AA-mäßig, A-A-B-B, A-A-B-B, oder wir machen halt wieder das, wir machen wieder A jetzt, A-B-A-B. Irgendwann haben ja alle Firmen ein Logo und dann die Designer so, puh, dann. Okay, das war, Leute, gute Arbeit, gut gemacht, waren ein paar harte Jahre, aber ich würde sagen, alle Firmen haben Logo und damit sind wir alle arbeitslos. Einmal Applaus. Die erste Branche, die es geschafft hat, einmal komplett fertig zu werden. Äh, Leute, ich habe aber noch Rechnungen zu zahlen. Ich muss noch... Wir haben alle Logos entworfen, wir sind durch. Wir sind jetzt hier durch. Alles klar. Okay, ihr packt schon zusammen, die Stühle wandern wieder auf die Tische, aber ich glaube, ich habe jetzt halt gerade irgendwie, ich habe mir so einen großen Pool geholt. Ja, ich auch, geil. Ja genau, aber das hat ja laufende Kosten. Ah, wirklich? Ja, du brauchst ja regelmäßig Geldeinkommen. Kannst du nicht ein Logo für laufende Poolkosten designen? Ich glaube nicht, dass das so funktioniert. Leute, Leute, kommt mal wieder alle rein, zieht die Jacken wieder aus. Zieht die Jacken bitte wieder aus. Oder wenn es euch zu kalt ist, lasst sie auch an. Wir wollen das gar nicht. Und du könntest auch gerne das Shirt ausziehen. Also, aber, hör mal auf, das ist egal jetzt gerade. Ja, okay. Ich meine nur, wenn die Temperatur gerade ein Problem ist. Markus, es ist doch jetzt wirklich nicht so wichtig.
Ich sag nur, du kannst deinen Chat ausziehen.
Wir haben alles da. Wir haben von Handschuhe bis zur Bademode ist alles hier. Greift doch einfach rein, was ihr braucht. Das ist wirklich kein Thema. Ich glaube einfach nur, dass wir ein Problem haben, wenn wir keine Arbeit mehr haben. Wir brauchen neue Logos. Ich habe eine Mail bekommen. Pepsi will das Logo ändern. Yes! Sie können es ändern. Aber es gibt Branchen, die zwischendurch einfach mal fertig sind?
Haben Müllmänner mal irgendwann den Müll gesammelt und gibt es dann immer so kurze Moment, wo man denkt, we done it. Ich glaube so bei der Mondlandung, oder? So, wuh, wir sind auf dem Mond! Okay. Was machen wir als nächstes? Mars? Nee, unmöglich. Nee, ist das jetzt mal möglich. Saturn? Viel zu weiter. Krass, eine Industrie hat es geschafft, das Ziel erreicht, Mond erreicht und es gibt kaum eine, die dann mehr angezweifelt wurde auch. Das heißt, doppelt undankbar, du bist fertig, unbefriedigend, sau unbefriedigend auf dem Mond. Ja, sau unbefriedigend. Am Ende, weil am Ende, unter vorgarten Händen mal kurz, ist es auch nur der Mond. Es ist nur der Mond, es ist der Nächste, es ist der Nachbar. Jesus Christus. Es ist der Nachbar. Da gehst du Hund, wenn du dir ein Ei leihen willst oder so fürs Wochenende. Oh, oh, Dominis Sanctus! Es ist nur der Mond und Gott sagt, nein! Ich bin der Mond! Ich gab euch den Mond zum Lernen, zum Bestaunen. Ja, wir haben Fenster und wir sind bereit, sie zu nutzen. Die Fenster sind alle auf Kipp heute. Nee, echt. Anstatt ein Fenster komplett aufzumachen, werden alle gekippt einfach. Alle, alle gekippt. Als du gerade meines, früher gab es ein neues Medium, das hast du vor, ich weiß nicht, bestimmt 30 Minuten gesagt, die Symphonie, ja da habe ich gedacht, wann die ersten Zeitungen die Kreuzworträtsel gestellt haben und der erste Mensch, der dann gelesen hat, der zuerst mal eine Frage gelesen hat in der Zeitung, muss wahnsinnig irritiert slash sauer gewesen sein, dass plötzlich die Zeitung Fragen stellt. Stimmt. Was war der erste Präsident von den Vereinigten Staaten? Ja, sag du es mir doch! Du bist doch die fucking Zeitung!
Alles, was ich weiss, weiss ich durch die Zeitung.
Ich habe drei Pennies ausgegeben für dieses Stück Papier und Sie stellen mir die Frage, was ist für Ihre Belustigung?
Sie belustigen mich nicht.
Ich musste zwei meiner Kinder verkaufen, um diese Zeitung zu erwerben.
Sie belustigen mich nicht. Sie geben mir die Nachrichten, sie sagen mir, was morgen passiert, sie sagen mir, wie das Wetter wird, aber sie stellen mir nicht Fragen.
Es ist ein, das wir mir, was morgen passiert, sie sagen mir, wie das Wetter wird, aber sie stellen mir nicht Fragen. Es gibt noch ein anderes Wort, das da kreuz und dann kannst du die kombinieren. Sie stellen mir noch eine weitere Frage? Ja, was ist albern witzig? Weißt du ein bisschen, was ich albern und witzig finde? Dass sie plötzlich anfangen, mir Fragen zu stellen. Als Dreckszeitungsverleger. Ja, wir haben, uns sind die Antworten ausgegangen. Moment, aber die Fragen nicht? Nein, wir haben noch einen ganzen Sack voller Fragen übrig. Aber jetzt beißt sich die Boa Constrictor in den Schwanz, weil wenn ihnen die Antworten ausgehen, aber die Fragen nicht, dann entwickeln sie doch einfach die Antworten auf die Fragen, die ihnen nicht ausgegangen sind.
Das heißt, sie wollen, dass wir das gelöste Kreuzworträtsel abdrucken.
Mindestens das.
Okay, pass auf.
Morgen. Kaufen morgen nochmal.
Dann kommen wir.
Ah, morgen kriegst du die Lösung für das heutige Kreuzworträtsel. Aber dann muss ich dir morgen auch kaufen. Smart, smart, Jerry. Yes. Jerry, der Zeitungsverleger. Klug, schlau, mit fünf Buchstaben. Smart. Bin ich verstanden. Ich bin nicht gebildet, weil es damals noch nicht, die Bildung war noch nicht. Die Mücke hat mich gestichen. Gestichen, geht es gerade gestichen? Gestern hat sie mich gestichen. Oh, weißt du was da? Und hat meine Grammatik mir rausgesaugt, das ist die Grammatikfliege. Es ist insane, es gibt nämlich diese so kleine Aufsätze, also so kleine, siehst aus wie so, weiß nicht, so Lippenstift-Dinger, und die werden heiß vorne. Das ist so eine kleine Metallfläche, die werden heiß. So sieht's aus. Genau, so sieht's aus. Und damit kannst du dann, wenn du frisch gestochen bist und du kriegst gerade so einen juckenden Mückenstich, machst du es drauf. Dann wird es ganz doll heiß, aber es ist auch irgendwie sauber befriedigend, weil du auf diese Stelle so attackierst die Rangeln. So wird es präzise. Und es ist super heiß und es wird super unangenehm, aber ich liebe diesen Schmerz in dem Moment. Weiss ich auch nicht warum, aber ich lieb's einfach. Also macht mich wahnsinnig an, dieser geile Schmerz.
Benutzt du das auch manchmal, obwohl du gar nicht gestochen wurdest? Oder denkst du, lässt du dich absichtlich stechen?
Stich mich, stich mich. Ich bin an so einem See in Schweden, wo es feucht ist, wo die Mücken nur so rumschwirren.
Hey, wir haben übrigens das Anti-Mückenspray für alle dabei. Stefan, willst du auch was?
Gib mir eine Kürze Flasche und dann nehme ich die und schmeiße sie in See.
Und dann ist es so geil, weil das ist so viel geil.
Dann machst du es auf dieser Stelle und es hört sofort auf,
nach diesem brennenden, stechenden, geilen Schmerz, hört es auf zu jucken, weil irgendwie ein Whatever, Protein, was auch immer,
wird genau, was dieses Juckreiz auslöst, wird irgendwie dann zu heiß. Es ist quasi Schmerzbarzahlung. Also wenn du normalerweise insgesamt 100 Schmerzpunkte hast auf eine Woche verteilt und du sagst, nee, nee, gib mir 100 Schmerzpunkte jetzt in einer Sekunde. Genau. Und du kannst, also das ist natürlich die Frage, also wenn du so, also Herr Tietze, Sie haben dieses Bein gebrochen, mit zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder das tut jetzt drei Wochen lang mittelmässig weh oder wir könnten natürlich auch machen. Ich sollte dringend aufhören E-Scootern zu fahren. In der Tat, aber ich sag mal so, wir verdienen gut dran, also wir beschweren uns nicht. Oder sie gehen in diese Schmerzkammer und erfahren fünf Sekunden lang den gesamten Schmerz. Ja, das. Sind Sie sich wirklich sicher? Der Schmerz ist enorm. Ja, das Schmerz. Aber der Schmerz ist wirklich unerträglich, aber dann ist er auch fähig. Konzentriert auf mein Bein? Konzentriert auf Ihr Bein, fünf Sekunden. Ja, wirklich. Ich würde nicht mehr mit der Wimper zucken. Sie können sie auch gerade nicht wegen den Antibiotika, aber das können wir dann alles in der Kammer erklären. Was geben Sie für Antibiotika, dass ich meine Augen nicht mehr bewegen kann? Jetzt stehen ein bisschen viele Fragen. Okay, dann in die Kammer. Viele Fragen. Aber das war wirklich damals ein Punkt, wo Leute irritiert waren. In Zeitungen stehen Fragen nicht mit mir, das gibt's nicht. Und das sind diese ersten Momente, wo es dann so gekippt hat. Die Zeitungen waren zu faul. Genau, ab dann ging es bergab. Und ich meine, den Niedergang des Print erleben wir jetzt quasi in Echtzeit. Genau, hat jetzt sehr lange gedauert, also hat sich sehr lange eigentlich noch hingehalten. Ja, stimmt. Man muss sagen, eigentlich Respekt. Gut Überleben, ja, über Wasser gehalten. Das stimmt schon. Ja, finde ich super. Bist du ein Kreuzworträtsel-Fan? Löst du das? Ja, ich lös es nicht, aber ich bin Fan. Ich komme mir Fragen an. Du schaust gerne Sport, aber machst selber keinen Sport. Na genau, richtig. Und du schaust bei der Kreuzworträtsel-WM zu, aber hast selber noch nie angerührt. Ich schaue den zu, ich sitze oben mit so einem Fähnchen und feuer dann jemanden an, guckt mir gern die Kommentatoren an und so was und irgendwie das als Event. Trinkt dabei gern Bierchen oder so was. Aber selber will ich das nicht machen. Was isst du? Ja, so Chicken Fingers. Was isst du mit fünfzehn Buchstaben? Auch wenn das stimmen würde, Chicken Fingers? Funt zählt mit seinen Händen. Florentin zählt mit seinen Händen. Oh, es sind vierzehn, glaub ich. Alter, wie gut das wär. Ist das deine Superkraft, dass du immer sagen kannst, wie viele Buchstaben irgendwas haben? Ja, sag mir ein Wort. Nationalhymne. Fünf, dreißig, nein, neun und achtzig Buchstaben. Okay, das war eine ganz kurze Superkraft. Du hattest für einen kurzen Zeitraum eine große Superkraft. Ich habe neulich mit einem Freund eine Übung erfunden, eine Sozialübung, um im sozialen Umgang besser, schnell und besser zu sein. Die Übung ist, ich sage dir jetzt eine Summe für ein Essen im Restaurant und du sagst mir sofort den Betrag, den du gibst mit Trinkgeld. Mit Trinkgeld? Die Übung heißt Trinkgeld schnell erraten und schnell
sagen, ohne lange zu überlegen
zehn Prozent.
58.
Der Betrag ist 58 Euro.
60.
Finde ich zu wenig. Du hast das Spiel verloren.
Unangenehm, das wäre ein super unangenehmer
Moment. Kellner ist irritiert.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so viel für Essen ausgegeben. Ich bin eher auf kleineren. Okay, gib mir noch einen. Du gehst frühstücken, bitte. Gib mir noch einen. 12,30 Euro. 15 Euro. Das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen zu viel, ehrlich gesagt. So schlecht in dem Spiel. Aber ganz kurze Zwischenfrage. Ich rufe an, beim Restaurant sagt, Freunde, pass auf, wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen,
ich sag euch jetzt, was ich will und in 15 Minuten komme ich vorbei und holt es ab, zum Abholen.
Und dann gehe ich da hin, gebe ich dann Trinket die Autos ein.
Erstmal vielen Dank, dass Sie zum Orakel von Delphi gekommen sind. Das Orakel Delphi, Trademark. Ich bin drei Wochen lang durch die Berge gewandert, um euch, oh weisses Orakel, diese Frage zu stellen. Stimmt, und du gehst da hin. Heutzutage ist das Orakel von Delphi bei so einem Touri-Ort, der so, daneben ist dann so eine Informationshütte, da kann man so Broschüren kaufen, wie sie mit dem Orakel reden und sowas. Souvenirs. Genau, das ist so abgezäunt und es sieht einigermaßen gefranchised mässig aus. Hat doch so ein Logo, das Orakel, auch nicht so wunderschön gemacht, sondern so touristisch halt. Ist so ein bisschen abgewetzt schon. Leute machen dann Fotos, stehen dann mit ihren Handys und machen so Selfies vom Orakel, ist ein bisschen abgewetzt, genau, irgendwie auch falsch überlaufen, 6000 Tourist am Tag, man muss ewig, wir standen in der Sonne, jetzt standen wir zwei Stunden schon in der Sonne. Ja, aber dafür sind so Verkäufer, die so Wasser verkaufen für acht Euro die Flasche oder so, super Abzocke und dann so Touristengruppen, so eine Führung, die erklären in verschiedenen Sprachen, los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los los Baby schreien. Es ist schrecklich eigentlich.
Aber nach eineinhalb Stunden warten.
Orakel von Delphi kann ich nie mehr empfehlen.
Zwei von fünf Sterne.
Antwort war super.
Antwort hat mein Leben verändert.
Aber nach eineinhalb Stunden bist du endlich am Orakel von Delphi und fragst, wo weiss ist Orakel von Delphi?
Muss ich Trinkgeld geben, wenn ich zum Abholen bestelle und dort Bar zahle im Restaurant? Nein. Man kriegt die Antwort auch direkt per Mail? Und das ist ja praktisch. Okay, wunderbar. Ist das die zweite Frage?
Die haben drei Fragen.
Ach, ich habe drei Fragen. Ja, Sie kriegen die Antwort auch direkt per Mail.
Ich habe drei Fragen?
Ja, Sie kriegen die Antwort auch direkt per Mail.
Und dann Papa.
Papa.
Hey, das tut mir leid.
Kein Refund, kein Refund.
Noch kurz ein, warum machen Restaurants dann so dumme Preise mit 8,20 Euro, wenn man dann so wahnsinnig viel rausgeben muss? Also machen die das nicht, damit man Trinkgeld gibt? Nein. Die Antwort auf warum ist nein? Okay, ich stelle mich hier nochmal hinten an. Es kostet dann aber noch immer 20 mal 20 Euro. Ach, sau teuer. Ich habe das Gefühl, die haben das Geld aus. Also ich würde das nicht empfehlen. Man schreibt Herbert aus Karlsruhe, schon in so einen langen Yelp-Artikel. Antwort hat mein Lebensverändert, ja, aber wir standen da super lang an, die Schlange, zwei Stunden. Das Wasser war sau teuer, es gab keine Toilette. Es gab einen K das sind Kiosk, das sind Verkäufer. Tipp, vorher genug Wasser und dann so, wie man die Reise am besten plant. Tipp, sich vorher die Fragen überlegen. Wir sind spontan morgens hin. Wir sind spontan morgens aus dem Hotel hin. Genau, wir dachten, unser Flug hat sich verschoben und dann dachten wir, wir gehen spontan noch hin. Schlechte Idee. Nichts spontan zu empfehlen. Leerzeichen, Ausrufezeichen. Und man denkt, Jesus fucking Herbert, ey. Leerzeichen, Ausrufezeichen. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Das machen so viele Leute. So viel Aufwand, Franzosen vor allem. Aber in Frankreich ist es tatsächlich so. In Frankreich macht man vor Ausrufezeichen noch ein Leerzeichen, da ist es leider so. Hat mich auch sehr geärgert, aber ist tatsächlich einfach so. Andere Regeln.
Why? Ich weiß es nicht, die wollen die Welt brennen sehen, die wollen die Monarchie ab, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es so ein revolutionärer Akt, keine Ahnung, was weiß ich denn die Franzosen machen. Weil ich finde, wenn so ein Satz geschrien ist und dann hängt das Ausrufzeichen da hinten dran, denke ich mir, passt, stimme ich. Aber wenn da erst der Satz läuft so geschrien aus. Ja. Und dann kommt dieses Signifikat dafür, dass es jetzt geschrien ist. Genau. Es ist wie so ein Stolperer nochmal. Wenn du wütend gegen die Wand hauen willst, aber du haust daneben, du haust in die Pflanze, die so gar nicht nachgibt. Wo du denkst, das war jetzt nichts. Wenig zielgerichtet. Null zielgerichtet. Viel besser machen es die Spanier nochmal als wir, die am Anfang schon sagen. Ja, jetzt kommt, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Aula, so jetzt wird es laut, so jetzt muss ich auch mal laut werden, finde ich aber eine mega gute Idee, so legendäre Orte als langweilige Touristenorte, also auch so der brennende Busch oder so, der brennende Busch irgendwo in der Wüste und auch so abgesperrt, so Zaun und dann wirklich mit so Überwachungskameras
und an so einer langen Schlange.
Der ist viel kleiner als gedacht.
Das Feuer ist überhaupt nicht warm.
Das ist viel kleiner als gedacht, wir haben uns das
groß vorgestellt, Marianne und ich, meine Frau, waren
sehr enttäuscht und man fährt da ewig lang
raus, da haben wir in diesem stickigen Bus gesessen
die ganze Zeit, der Busfahrer war
sichtlich übermüdet, wir sind da hingefahren,
man kommt so eine Serpentinenstrasse. Wahnsinnig langes, lautes Autoradio im Bus und er wollte es nicht abschalten, obwohl wir ihn mehrfach drum gebeten haben. Ein Buschbus, ein brennender Busbusch, Bus, Buschbus. Warum hast du das nicht geändert, nicht editiert? Und dann bitte kein Müll im Busch verbrennt, so ein großes Schild, so ein Warnschild. Nicht die Flamme entzünden, kein Benzin. Ja, genau. Brennende Busch. Aber finde ich nicht schlecht. Es gibt so ein paar Orte in der Geschichte, die man jetzt aber keine Ahnung, die sind dann so, ich finde die sind Turimäßig überlaufen. Brennende Busch. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wäre es nicht eine coole Idee, so eine Art Comedy-Attraktion zu haben. Also so eine Art Ort, der offensichtlich Bullshit ist, aber halt einfach Comedy, so eine Parodie auf einen Tourismusort. Kunstinstallation. Genau, sowas wie der brennende Busch und dann hast du halt so auch Parodie auf so kirchlichen Tourismus und Abzockern mit so Reliquien und sowas in der Richtung. Aber es ist halt alles Comedy und da kommen dann auch Schauspieler, so ein irgendwie so Moses oder sowas um die Ecke oder irgendwelche fanatischen Rieger. Briegel der Busch? Briegel der Busch, sowas. Aber ich glaube, eine Zielgruppe. Buschi. Das Maskottchen. Genau, Buschi. So eine grosse Buschflamme. Walking Character. Buschi kollabiert aber immer wegen Hitzeschlag. Und dann kommen so zwei Mitarbeiter. Ich will so wirklich so Hardcore-Mitarbeiter, die so grellgrüne T-Shirts mit Cap haben, die dann immer so mit so einem Feuerlöscher dann so Wasser in den reinspritzen. Und er kollabiert immer wieder. Und er wird immer wieder hinter die Kulissen gezogen. Und dann sind die Leute, die ihn wiederbeleben und so Chest-Compressions machen für eine halbe Stunde. In fünf Minuten später talken, Buschi wieder so raus und ihm geht's offensichtlich nicht gut. Buschi und Flämli. Flämli ist dann die Flamme, die dann kommt. Das sind die Walking-Characters, aber hier Foto kostet fucking 20 Euro. Die Kinder sind dann, Kinder quengeln, Kinder schreien, gehen dann hin, Buschig kippt um. Und dann kommt ab und zu so ein Mitarbeiter, der noch mal so einen neuen Reifen in den brennenden Busch wirft, damit das Feuer am brennen bleibt. Der hat aber jetzt ein Umschneid-Mikrofon und sagt dann, ja, ab und zu muss man jetzt hier, und auch alles in der Sprache, die man nicht versteht, weil man die falsche Tour gebucht hat.
Abstand bitte, nehmen Sie einen Schritt zurück.
Man kann gar nicht nah ran.
Und die Fotos werden so, so scheiße.
Absolut überbelichtet, einfach das Feuer ist fucking grä.
Aber es gibt so Teleskope, die am Rand stehen,
wo du so durchgucken kannst, für einen Euro musst du reinwerfen,
dann kannst du so in den Busch gucken.
Aber die sind auch schon kaputt, die meisten sind kaputt.
Aber das finde ich mega gut, aber ich glaube, einfach das Problem ist, dass Touristen sind nicht die Zielgruppe für Comedy. Ich glaube, die haben ja gar keinen Bock drauf. Ich glaube, du hättest zu viele echte Touristen, die aber wieder lustig sind für die Leute, die aus Spaß da sind. Aber finde ich keine schlechte Idee. Und dann auch diese Pressen, wo man so ein Sendstück reinmacht und dann pressen die so dieses brennende Busch-Logo, brennen die dann da drauf. Ich finde das alles so gut, ich finde das super. Ja, könnte man machen, so eine Reihe dann irgendwie. Das Orakel von Delphi und dann diese Touribusse, die da hinfahren und so, alles ganz schrecklich. Finde ich aber eine gute Idee, du hast dann irgendwie so ein Mikrofon in so einer kleinen Bude und dann hörst du das immer im Orakel, in der Höhle. Nein, no. Alemanje, oispanol. Alemanje. Oispanol. Herzlich willkommen zum Orakel von Delphi. Stellen Sie jetzt Ihre erste Frage. Werde, die Frau, mit der ich hier bin, sind wir, werden wir glücklich zusammen? Nein. Die Frage hat mich zu Ende gestellt, Jesus. Werde ich denn noch meine Frau und Frau kennenlernen? Nein. Jesus. Okay. Sie haben noch eine Frage, liebt mich mein Kind.
Nein. Vielen Dank, dass Sie das Orakel von Delphi besucht haben. Bitte kommen Sie gerne wieder. Ausgang links. Ausgang links. Ausgang links. Bitte machen Sie schnell Platz für die nächste Gruppe hinter Ihnen. Um einen reibungslosen Ablauf beim Orakel vonvon-Delphi-Team. Aber Delphi ist ja ein Ort, oder? Also gibt es da wirklich irgendwas?
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Delphi ist doch ein Ort, Ort einfach.
Orakel von...
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich irgendwo in Griechenland.
Gibt es da irgendwas oder gibt es da gar nichts?
Oder ist es wie so der Olymp, das einfach nur so ein Berg ist, aber wo man...
Das Orakel von Delphi war eine Weissagungsstätte des antiken Griechenlands, sie befand sich am Hang des Parnas, bei der Stadt Delphi in der Landschaft Fokis. Die Kultstätte von Delphi mit dem Orakel war die wichtigste der hellenischen Welt und bestand bis in die Spätantike. Delphi gilt lange Zeit sogar als Mittelpunkt der Welt, der symbolisch durch den Omphalus markiert wurde. Möchten Sie weitere Informationen über Delphi, so drücken Sie bitte die... Nein! Delphi ist noch eine Stadt, und zwar hieß die ursprünglich Pytho, ist jetzt nur so, also ist nicht so wichtig, nur ich will es jetzt auch nicht ignorieren. Ja, es muss einfach gesagt werden. Er war eine Stadt im Antiken Griechenland, die vor allem von der Orakel bekannt war. Die vor allem für eines Rückrages. Seit 1987 gehören die Ausgrabungen von Delphi zu der Liste der Gruppe. So, das ist alles in Griechenland. Ich finde es hier, Lage von Delphi ist bei Stratos. Danke. Da fährt immer die Stratosphäre. Okay. In Stratosphäre wirklich? In Stratos fährt die Stratosphäre. Okay. Cool. Gut. Ja, danke. Alles klar. Dankeschön. Ich habe neulich etwas gemacht um mein, keine Ahnung, etwas um mein Weltbild ein bisschen angefasst. Weil ich habe morgens Zeit gehabt, irgendwie war es super früh
und ich bin einkaufen gegangen,
Klamotten einkaufen gegangen
und war dann bei P&C und zwar morgens,
als es der Laden aufgemacht hat,
um zehn Uhr und es ist so merkwürdig,
weil in Köln der Laden ist riesig
gross und der ist ja immer sauvoll.
Ich brauchte neue Klamotten und bin dann dahin
und es war um zehn Uhr morgens, war der ganze P&C
halt komplett leer, nur alle Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen waren halt schon da. Und das sind viele. Es wirkt nicht so, wenn der Laden voll ist. Ja, es verteilt ist. Aber es war so merkwürdig. Es war der erste Kunde in diesem riesigen P&C. Und es war irgendwie eine wilde Erfahrung. Und das kann ich nur empfehlen, macht mal Dinge zu merkwürdigen Uhrzeiten, weil plötzlich nimmt man die Welt ganz anders wahr. Der Laden macht ja auf. Dieses Riesenkonstrukt hat ja auch Türen, die einfach jemand aufschließt morgens und dann kommen Leute zur Arbeit und ziehen die sich noch um. Ja, ich würde erwarten, dass sie noch gar nicht bereit sind, dass sie noch so den Text durchgehen, so mit so Karteikarten, noch so Grösse L im Lager, Grösse XL, kann ich ihnen noch Socken anbieten, so und dann kommst du rein, so wow, wow, was und du einfach gar nicht erwarten. Ja, so ein bisschen wie so Truman Show, überrascht du die. Die Illusion ist noch nicht aufgebaut, die Kulisse steht noch nicht. Steht noch nicht und die haben noch so ihre Jacke anziehen, die dann aus, haben noch so Teambesprechungen, was habt ihr jetzt zu besprechen, Ihr müsst mir nur sagen, wo die Grösse jetzt ist. Und dann war aber auch Ruhet, weil P&C ist ja pleite. P&C ist jetzt insolvent. Der Laden denkt, die gibt es. Ist es Piep und Kloppenburg? Pieck und Kloppenburg. Es gibt nicht mehr Kloppenburg als fucking Pieck Kloppenburg. Und ich finde es irgendwie spannend, weil mein Kopf, ich glaube, ist normal, geht dann immer sofort gedanklich dahin, dass der Laden pleite ist, es ist ein failed business. Und irgendwie ist mir das dann auch aufgefallen, so in jeder Interaktion. Dann habe ich zum Beispiel, weil wenn man allein in diesem Laden ist, dann wird man so 20 Verkäufer um dich herum die ganze Zeit. Ziel einfach. Man ist wie so die weißen Lutkörperchen, wenn ich mir vorstelle, wie die auf Fremdkörper reagieren, haben die dann auch so direkt mich so als Fremdkörper ausgemacht, so einen grossen Lutsch, der herumlief und ganz viele Bügel in der Hand hatte. Dann habe ich eine Frage gestellt. Du wolltest nur Kleiderbügel kaufen, oder was? Deswegen warst du da. Kleiderbügel kaufen, klauen. Und dann bin ich hin und habe, kann ich Ihnen helfen, dann habe ich gesagt, ja, was ich suche, habe ich sie gefragt und sie hat gesagt, eines haben wir hier nicht. Da müssen sie, weiß ich nicht, zu Kost zum Beispiel gehen. Und ich so, okay. Ich habe das dann ignoriert und habe dann das Item gefunden, aber noch bei Pieke-Klockenburg und habe dann gedacht, aber ist ja auch klar, dass sie Pleite gemacht haben. Wenn ihr nicht mal wisst, was sie ja haben.
Ja, genau, also sie hatten das Item da, etwas dieser Art, was ich beschrieben hatte, und sie hat gesagt, nee, so was haben wir hier nicht. Will ich mit so einem belustigten, nee, das haben wir hier nicht. Wir haben hier keine Rohrreiniger. Und dann hab ich aber das tatsächlich dann da gefunden, dieses Item, und das war, da dachte ich mir, Leute. Und dann fällt man aber auch so auf, keine Ahnung, unten war da niemand Gürtel sortiert noch.
Das waren diese Sachen, die man morgens um zehn Uhr halb macht, wenn man den Laden besucht ist. Was man am Tag davor noch nicht mehr geschafft hat. Und dann lagen diese ganzen Gürtel aber über den Unterhosen. Wollte ich aber mir eigentlich Unterhosen kaufen. Und dann lagen halt diese ganzen, und dann dachte ich mir, das ist einfach, dieses Business, es hat sich nicht viel verändert. Es ist immer noch, bei uns ist ja, wahrscheinlich als grosse, komplexe Gründe, warum dieser Laden zugemacht hat. Aber dann ist man da. Im Kleinen einfach, weil die Gürtel im Weg sind. Aber im Kleinen fällt mir dann auf, ja, weil sie mich wegschicken, obwohl sie das Produkt haben, weil sie die Gürtel auf die Produkte legen, die ich gerne kaufen würde. Und dann bin ich ja so kopfschüttelnd mit dem, ja, ist ja logisch, warum das hier alles nicht funktioniert, rumgelaufen. Aber das ist so gemein auch, weil man halt der Laden... Es ist gemein, vor allem wenn du wüsstest, dass der Laden mega erfolgreich ist, du wirst denken, oh krass, die können sich es erlauben, die Gürtel auf die Waren zu legen und mich wegzuschubsen und mich dumm anzugucken, vielleicht sind die deswegen so erfolgreich. Der Wert, den du einem Laden beimisst, ist ja oft auch einfach, weil der Laden das ausstrahlt, zum Beispiel, also Apple ist ja, du merkst immer, krass erfolgreich ist, einer der wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt. Dann gehst du da rein und dann, wenn etwas da schiefläuft, denkst du, ah gut, ich bin dessen nicht würdig. Es hat schon alles eine Landesberechtigung. Dann hörst du aber halt leider, dass es dann irgendwie jetzt so Insolvenzkram gibt. Und dann noch unglücklich war das erste Gespräch, was ich mitbekommen habe zwischen zwei Mitarbeiterinnen, die dann da waren, ging auch um, ja, ich glaube, es muss noch eine Insolvenzsache geklärt werden. Das war so ein Schnitzel, den ich so mitbekommen habe, wo ich dachte, ah krass, hier ist alles gerade so Untergang. Das war so Finde Sierke-mäßig. Es war super spannend, da diese, so kurz vorm Ende dieses grossen Kolosses Pik und Kloppen, wo es ein riesen Laden ja auch ist, so reinzugehen. Und ich finde das so spannend, weil dieser Insolvenzprozess ist ja jetzt so einigermaßen, weiss man davon, und dann ist aber alles, was man in diesem Laden sieht, bezieht man sofort auf, es ist ein Failed Business, es ist was Bescheid und verurteilt. Du wirst auch sofort zum Experten so, ja natürlich, deswegen funktioniert es nicht. Na klar, wegen der Unterhosen funktioniert es nicht. Dann wollte ich mich ... Dann willst du Tipps geben, Entschuldigung, aber so kann es auch nicht weitergehen. Genau. Und dann war ich in der Umkleide. Das war so eine Umkleide, die war nicht da, wo am Rand die Umkleide waren, sondern irgendwie so inmitten des Raumes. Und das hatte keinen Vorhang. Und dann habe ich gesagt, Leute, also, um Kleide, warum? Man wird dann so zu so einem Konsulten. Das versteht ja jeder. Das kann ja nicht funktionieren. Dann fangen wir nochmal bei den Basics an. Umkleidekabinen brauchen Sichtschutz. Dann kann man mit so einem Fünf-Punkte-Plan, wie ich P&C retten will. Naja, ich fand das nicht schlecht. Aber es stimmt, der Eindruck macht wahnsinnig viel aus. Natürlich auch zum Thema, ich habe mich mit der Weindoku beschäftigt, die du gesagt hast, mit diesen Sommeliers. Somm. Megacool, superinteressant, extrem beeindruckend, was der Mensch leisten kann und schmecken kann. Und das ist ja Wein ... Also der Mensch, nicht du. Nee, absolut, der Mensch an sich. Wein bewegt sich immer so zwischen kompletter Bullshit und überteuert und nur Glamour und nur Worte. Kunst, ja. Aber die Leute haben auch echt Ahnung davon. Und ich dachte mir, Mann, ich, ich hätte auch Bock irgendwie sowas zu haben, wo man so richtig seine Geschmackssinne trainieren kann, weil ich bin da wirklich eine geschmackliche Mülltonne, so, ich krieg nichts mit, da dachte ich mir, ich mag halt kein Alkohol und da kommt man sofort so auf Whisky und Wein und Gin, ich mag das halt alles nicht und da dachte ich mir, komm, warum denn nicht mal wieder zurück zu meiner guten alten Leidenschaft, Tee.
So, Tee, da gibt es auch viel Varianz und da kann man auch sagen, das ist jetzt hier der Hügel in Südostchina da, bla bla bla.
Und dann dachte ich mir, Tee, aber was brauchst du für ein neues Hobby?
Du brauchst eine Community, du musst irgendwie reinkommen, du musst dich irgendwie, du musst dich eigentlich aufsaugen,
du musst quasi irgendwie, du brauchst, so sind ein Teebeutel in deinem Leben, der dich anreichert. Und dann dachte ich mir, für mich natürlich die erste Anlaufstelle für Communities ist natürlich Reddit. Ja, also gehe ich auf Reddit Tee, einfach Tee, Tee, Eee. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, hier ist eine Community, die lieben Tee genauso wie ich, stellt sich raus, es ist eine Community für T-Shirts. Es ist für T-Shirts, wo Leute ihre T-Shirts-Designs hochladen, über T-Shirt-Grössen reden, also einfach T-Shirt-Liebhaber. Bis auf eine Person. Denn dieses Reddit, was komplett amerikanisch ist, also komplett international irgendwie, und ein Post fand ich da doch interessant
zwischen Sachen wie
Would this look good on a T-Shirt?
Pack fruitin, neues T-Shirt-Design
und ein Post
Gurgeltee nicht zum Verzehr geeignet.
Zeig mal!
Der ist genauso falsch abgewogen
wie du. Das heißt,
unter diesem offensichtlichen T-Shirt
Reddit gibt es einen Post von OK Requirement, der oder die fragt, Gurgeltee nicht zum Verzehr, geeignet auch straight deutsch. Null Kommentare, null Upvotes, völlig ignoriert und irgendwie tat mir diese Person so leid. und verschrieben, dass sie so nennen. Hi, ich habe mir Rachen und Grugeltee, er meinte Grugeltee, aus der Apotheke gekauft.
Das ist einfach nur Salbe. Leid, dass die ... Ist es da um die Dosierung des Salbei oder es ist möglicherweise eine Salbei-Art, die ungenießbar und nur zu äusserlichen Anwendungen geeignet ist? Lavendel gibt es zum Beispiel Sorten. Ich würde gerne drunter posten, einen Entwurf, ein T-Shirt-Design mit diesem Reddit-Post drauf. Das wäre mein Vorschlag. So, und dann so, Fragezeichen, wenn man einfach ein Shirt und so ein Salbei-Gurgel. Aber ich finde es so geil, einfach diese Frage, und ich stelle mir so einen grossen Raum von Leuten vor, die zuhören, aber dann so. Excuse me, what? This is the show. Is it, like, is the T-shirt too small or is it too big or is it? This is the international. Ich wollte wissen, weil im Gurgeltee, weil der Apotheker konnte es mir auch nicht beantworten. So you're like a XL large. Aber wie selbstbewusst auch einfach da. Und es hat doch niemand geantwortet seit zwei Monaten, ist der Post da, niemand hat geantwortet, auch nicht so, kein Upvote, auch nicht mal downgevotet.
Wenn ich ein internationales Reddit hätte und dann würde jemand in der Sprache schreiben, die ich nicht kenne, würde ich downvoten, aber nichts.
Und falls ihr euch mit Tee auskennt oder T-Shirt-Designer seid, helft doch dieser armen Person, die seit zwei Monaten diesen dampfenden Gurgeltee auf dem Tresen stehen hat.
Und ich weiss, kann ich den vor oder nach dem Gurgeln noch trinken, vielleicht könnt ihr helfen. Vor allem, ich bin gerade auf dem Profil des armen Kerls oder der armen Frau und es ist ein lieber Redditor, auch erfahren.
Ja, absolut.
Und die hat jemand geschrieben, die hat jemand ein Allgemeinwissen, das man in der Schule lernt, nachholen. Hi, ich habe damals in der Schulzeit am Gymnasium bei vielen Dingen nicht aufgepasst, und so sind viele Informationen in der Geschichte und hier haben wir vorbeigegangen, schreibt jemand. Und unser T-Guy schreibt dann darauf, ich, du und so weiter schreibt man in Briefen groß. Deswegen schreibe ich die hier auch groß. Also er hilft dann auch einfach Leuten. Und immer das Ende ist immer Peace. Das Ende ist immer das Peace Emoji, immer Peace out am Ende von jedem Post. Aber niemand hat reagiert. Also falls ihr euch entweder mit Tee oder mit T-Shirts auskennt, vielleicht kann das jemand sagen, weil ich kenne die Antwort nicht und das zeigt, wie wenig Ahnung ich von Tee habe. Ich habe die Frage nicht ganz verstanden. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Gurgeltee habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Gurgeltee noch trinken darf. Können wir nicht die, weil es hat nur 531 Mitglieder, das Tee-Subreddit. Können wir das nicht als deutsche Teenation, die wir ja sind, wir lieben Tee, schwarzer Tee. Aber das ist jetzt ein Putsch, ne? Aus Friesentee. Letzte Woche haben wir noch vom Putsch gesprochen und jetzt machen wir einen. Deutschland ist ein Teeland. Ist es ein Teeland wie England, weiß ich nicht. Haben wir aber als deutschsprachige Nationen, und ich möchte da auch gerne unsere Schweizer und österreichischen Kollegen und Kolleginnen mit einbeziehen, haben wir nicht als TEE das verdient. Absolut. Können die sich nicht auf T-Shirt committen, können die nicht alle umziehen. Auf T-Shirt, vielleicht gibt es ein Reddit-T-Shirt. Der große Reddit-Krieg. Wir sind doch mehr als 531 Redditor unter uns, oder? Wollen wir nicht den Subreddit-T, ich sag mal, umstrukturieren? Nee, du meinst übernehmen, du meinst putschen, du willst zum Putsch aufrufen. Erst mal werden wir Teil und dann strukturieren wir das von innen langsam um und sagen, ich finde den Tee-Schwerpunkt gut. Danke an alles, was hier bis lang geleistet wurde. Wir mögen auch Tee. Wer noch? Es ist der grosse Bärhack. Wir übernehmen das Ganze über die komplette Staffel. Vielleicht können wir erst mal anfangen mit T-Shirts, auf denen Tee drauf ist. Genau. Dass es so ein sanfter Übergang ist. Ich meine auch. So ein Teebeutel auf einem T-Shirt und dann irgendwann nur noch, ah, was ist das denn für ein Tee? Ah, und dann entwickelt sich es langsam und dann macht jemand einen Post auf, Fave-Tee-Sorten. Und dann irgendwann übernehmen wir das Ganze. Weil Deutschland ist doch, also wir haben sehr viele Bundesbürgerinnen und Bundesbürger und T T spielt schon eine grosse Rolle bei den Deutschen.
Und deswegen finde ich es jetzt gar nicht so schlecht,
jetzt freundlich, auf eine freundliche Art, das T-Subreddit,
weil es halt nur die deutsche Schreibweise T-E-E ist, zu übernehmen.
Hast du Verbindungen zu den Ostfriesen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, ohne die Ostfriesen kommen wir nicht weiter.
Das sind harte Burschen. Aber hast du Kontakte?
Können wir da einen Call machen?
Aber dann wird es eine feindliche Übernahme.
Können wir einen Call machen?
Mit denen wird es eine feindliche Übernahme.
Du machst sowas nicht friedlich, okay? Wenn wir so einen Teil übernehmen wollen, dann brauchen wir die Ostfriesen. Okay. Kay Candle. Kay Candle, ich krieg das hin. Ich glaube, sobald wir die Ostfriesen an Bord haben, ist das Ding übernommen. Ich gucke so viel Succession gerade, ich habe es, dass ich aufgeholt habe, bis zur neuen Folge. Aber du bist gerade, glaube ich, weiter als ich, also bitte nicht. Ich mer sage nichts, ich möchte auch Leuten nichts weiter, ich möchte nur sagen, grandiosere Serie, wow, krasser Geheimtipp, viel Spaß mit Succession unbedingt gucken. Aber ich gucke es gerade so viel, das passt ja auch zu mir als eine Persönlichkeitsveranlagung, dass ich mich dann so sehr rein nerde und so eine Phase entwickle, dass ich auch anfange, so wie die Charaktere zu sprechen. auch manchmal dass ich dann so du fluchst sehr viel ich fluche jetzt sehr viel und ich bin dann nicht jemand der gerne leute anruft zum beispiel aber ich habe neulich dann so ein business ding gehabt wo jemand was abgesagt hat habe ich ein paar ecken mit bekommen und ich dachte dann so ich könnte jetzt einfach so candle mässig anrufen und sagen hey man what the fuck what the fuck what the fuck yeah what the fuck happened man we had, man, come on, come on, you fucker. Und dann habe ich so angerufen. Und daraus ist ein tolles Gespräch geworden, ich war viel freundlicher als das, aber es hat mich auf eine gewisse Weise hat mich Succession aus meiner Comfort Zone, ich nehme meinen Hörer nicht in die Hand, geholt und dazu gebracht, dass ich dann jemanden angerufen habe und mit so einer, komm, wir können mal drüber reden, Art, sehr viel erreicht habe jetzt. Für alle, die sich wissen, es ist eine Serie über ein Familienunternehmen und Business und harte Typen, harte Bandagen und viele Deals, Intrigen und Business, wahnsinnig viel Geld, die sind alle unfassbar reich und ich wäre auch gerne reich. Und auf so eine, genau, wir wollen gerne Reichweite, aber wir fangen an, erstmal jetzt Florentin mit dem T-Subreddit. So ein bisschen als Testballon.
Ja. Ich bin auch in der Klasse bei Reich und ich wäre auch gerne Reich. Genau, wir werden auch gerne Reichweite, aber wir fangen an, Flo und die mit dem Tee-Subreddit. So ein bisschen als Testballon. Wir lassen den Testballon steigen. Aktuell heißt es, This Subreddit is dedicated to awesome, original, goofy, weird, lovely, neat, strange and random T-Shirts. Nicht mal das leider. Das heißt vielleicht ... Und es ist unter den Top 50 Prozent Subreddits. Ranked by size, ja, doch. Mit 530 Mitgliedern bist du da schon? Also das ist ein durchaus kleiner Fisch in einem dicken See. Vielleicht gibt es da Leute bei euch, die zwei Interessen haben, nämlich Shirts und Tees. Gut an Shirts ist, viele haben Shirts. Vor allem Vor allem, wir können die ganzen Peak- und Kloppenburg-Mitarbeiter, die sich gut mit T-Shirts auskennen, die können wir jetzt überführen zu Tee-Liebhabern. Weil wenn die jetzt alle sozusagen, wenn Peak-Kloppenburg untergeht und das Tee-Imperium währenddessen entsteht, können wir die ja direkt übernehmen. Das ist eine Umschulung. Es ist Peak-Tee. Ich mag die Vorstellung gerade sehr, dass wir diesen Subreddit zu einem deutschen Tee-Subreddit langsam machen. Aber langsam, also nicht da irgendwie zu prollen oder so, sondern das soll wirklich eine sanfte ... Erst mal können wir vielleicht dem Gurgel-Tee einfach mal helfen. Papwurz. Das kann ja so ein bisschen die Keimzelle sein, dieser Post mit dem Gurgel-Tee, dass der der erfolgreichste Post auf dem Sub ist und alle denken, wow, und daraus entsteht mehr. Genau, wir müssen uns in die Augen gucken und feststellen, dass dieser deutsche Kommentar über Tee der erfolgreichste Post ist. Ja, und dann brauchen wir eigentlich... Das, was die Leute wollen, wenn der Vorstand, der Vorstand in der Sub-Ready so, we gotta go where the people are going. What's the temperature? The temperature is people love the Google-Tee-Comment. It's a fact. They love it. They love to gurgle. Aber wir brauchen erstmal einen Moderator. Aber ich mag auch die Idee mit dem T-Shirt. Did you mean like this? Mit dem Tee auf dem T-Shirt. Ja, ich we müssen halt Moderator haben oder Moderatorin. Sonst können wir nämlich nicht diesen kleinen Text und den Zweck verändern. Wir brauchen einen undercover. Wir müssen jemanden, der an der Cover reingeht. Deswegen meine ich halt jemanden, der vielleicht T mag, aber halt auch T-Shirts. Ich glaube, der erste Schritt der Übernahme ist T-Shirt-Tees, T-T-Shirts, die da langsam reingehen. Und ich sogar mein T-T-Shirt geschenkt bekommen. T-Shirt? Ja. T-E-A minus Shirt. T-Shirt. Ja, langsam die Übernahme, Stück für Stück. Das ist die Hummer-Taktik, so der Hummer merkt gar nicht, dass er gekocht wird. Der Bärhag. Jeden Tag ein Grad mehr und irgendwann ist er tot und er weiß gar nicht warum. So, das ist die Idee. Wenn man stirbt, weiß man häufig häufig, glaube ich, selber nicht mehr warum. Na, ich glaube, manchmal merkt man, ah shit, ich falle gerade 50 Meter in die Tiefe. Das stimmt. Das ist wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee. Oh nein, der Boden kommt näher, ah nein, oh nein, oh nein, Stille, Stille, dann viel Stille. Aber ich habe, also ich bin auch so wie du, dass ich mir denke, geil, ich wäre auch so cool wie die in Succession und so, aber ich denke mir immer so,
erst mal muss man halt reich sein, weil
die können sich halt auch schon viel leisten, weil sie reich sind.
Und da kommt ihr ins Spiel.
Wir haben patreon.com slash das Podcast
UFO. Dieser Podcast
wäre cooler, wenn wir reich wären.
Die Geschichten wären cooler. Wir wären
in Dubai, Brüssel,
sowas, Ulaan Bato, wir hätten mehr zu erzählen.
Es ist ja auch für euch besser. Es ist ja für euch besser und die Rechnung ist doch ganz klar. Leute, kommen wir kurz zusammen. Wenn ihr uns mehr Geld gebt, kaufen wir uns zum Beispiel, jetzt mal nur vereinfacht gesprochen, bessere Betten. Schlafen besser, kommen ausgeschlafener in die Folge. Es ist eine Investition für euch, der Kurs steigt ein. Wir müssen nicht mehr putzen selber, wir haben Putzpersonal. Dadurch haben wir mehr Zeit, uns auf die Folgen lustig vorzubereiten. Oder mit unseren Bademäntel-Kimonos aus dem Fenster zu gucken, Leute zu beobachten, um spannende, lustige, clevere Beobachtungen zu machen. Wir können uns zum Beispiel einen Heißluftballon leisten, aus dem wir die Welt von oben betrachten können und neue innovative Blickwinkel bekommen. Clevere, coole Beobachtungen, die sind lustig, da lacht man sich kaputt. Dafür brauchen wir euer Geld. Patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO. Aber ansonsten, falls ihr Ideen habt, wie man reich wird, ich überlege schon die ganze Woche. Und ich bin halt nur auf Pfand gekommen, dass man irgendwie Pfand, die schon voll in den Pfandautomaten steckt, also dass man die aus dem Regal nimmt und voll in den Pfandautomaten steckt. Da machst du Gewinn, das ist völlig richtig. Aber ich habe das auch nicht ausprobiert. Und das ist vielleicht auch verboten. Aber das war jetzt so die erste Idee, die ich hatte. Ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr eine andere Idee habt, irgendwas mit Aktien oder EMTs oder irgendwie sowas, ETFs, EZBs, sowas, EDM, ESCs, ob man da nicht noch was machen kann. Aber aktuell bin ich bei Pfand. Ja, vielleicht sollst du dich auch von diesem Pfandthema lösen, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das sich zum Ziel bringt jetzt zwangsläufig. Da oben, oh Scheiss, unsere Nachbarin da oben hat Bienen, guck dir das mal an. Wo? Da oben auf dem Dach, unfassbar, eine Urban Beekeeperin, eine Imkerin, Queen, Bee-Queen. Oh, die trägt aber nicht dieses Outfit. Oh, I love it, eine Bee-Queen, go, Queen, bzzz. Fantastisch. Aber die hat nicht dieses Schutzoutfit, die scheint sehr eng zu sein mit den Bienen. Ich fände das ja so geil, einfach morgens schneide ich mit dem Brötchen auf, dann gehe ich mit dem Messer und dem feuchten Mund, gehe ich dann zu diesem Bienenstock, einmal das Messer durchziehen durch den frischen Honig, knallst mir auf mein Brot, dann beiß ich morgens in so mein Sonntagsbrötchen rein mit frischem Kölner Honig. Allein so eine Dachterrasse zu haben ist ja schon mega geil. Allein die Dachterrasse. Vergessen wir diese ganze Bienenscheisse kurz. Und einfach Bienenscheiße kurz. Warum haben wir diese dumm angewinkelten Dächer? Das ist ja die dümmste Idee. Ja, Dachterrassen sind geil. Die Dächer sind spitz, das ist eine dumme Idee. Ja, gebt uns Geld, dann nerven wir nicht mehr mit diesem Thema. Wir wollen so reich sein wie Succession, aber wir können auch eine Serie gucken, wo Leute arm sind. Dann wollen wir viel arm sein. Also es kann sich auch ändern. Ja, genau. Mal gucken. Also mal gucken, wie es die nächste Woche aussieht. Haut rein und habt eine schöne Woche.
Habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut.
Wir heben ab und sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Macht's gut, ihr Liebesbeschuss.
Sehen und sehen und tun uns nicht.
Tschüss, wir winken.
Tschaui, tschau, bye, bye, bye.
It's the worst bird production am Ende des Tages.